joining us now is Jack Nicklaus who
joins us from Augusta Jack good morning
how are you hey Dan how you doing I'm
doing okay and where are you at Augusta
right now well I'm sitting in a room
just off of the trophy room
oh nice okay yeah I wasn't sure what do
you still have a locker there yeah I
think I do okay what's in that locker
right now not much I would imagine
mail has come in from off-site that are
sent to me at Augusta every year and I
had my hey we have a champions locker
which all the champions have and then we
have the normal members locker room
which I have a locker in the locker room
to know I saw where yet issues with
security just getting into Augusta no I
didn't have any issues well they were
stopping yeah what I couldn't understand
what each other we had funny guy at him
and he says he's some well you gotta
scan your scan you're saying and I
looked at it he says he looked at
managers I don't think I need to scan
well they were like $5.00 there's like
five checkpoints to get in going up
Magnolia Lane there for you yeah I was
all right that's that's the way it goes
and I I think you know security is
important any word today did you watch
the 86 special last night on the Golf
Channel had you seen it before it aired
last night uh no I have not seen it then
it was I didn't see it last night we
were we were in the Masters dinner last
night at that time oh he was well done
we said there were sitting there with
telling jokes and having fun and I'll
have to Hollister watches it another
time what did you keep from that that
masters the do you have the putter plaid
pants do you have anything that you kept
well I've obviously got the memories and
I've got the the trophy that comes with
it but one thing that I don't have and
it's the only golf club that I don't
have
of all the turn of all the Tirpitz that
I've won and major championships there's
one true one one club I don't have it
that's putter I think that one of my
kids said it wasn't it was in the golf
room and one of the kids would say all
dad didn't use this thing anymore you
guys can have this oh he did that I
think Steve - Steve did it with my white
fang putter and somebody did it was the
other one I don't know which one we've
never found it we did find the white
thing yeah but we never found that one
how much joy do you take out of when you
did it how you did it at the age when
they they were starting to write you off
I took a lot of joy out of it I think it
was I didn't think I could do anything
anymore and you know I was and I
certainly didn't start the tournament
very excitingly I started with 74 then I
shot 71 and I shot 69 and you know I
said I've only got eight guys in front
of me in four shots behind and then you
know I had Jackie on the bag and my son
Steve called me from Hattiesburg or he's
working in the golf tournament and you
know I said what do you think pops and I
said you know 66 65 I take a win he says
that's the number I got mine go shoot it
well anyway you know it's sort of little
things sort of added up and when I got
in my I got and I and I didn't start
well on Sunday but then all of a sudden
every 9 10 and 11 and I said you never
know and so I got myself in contention
and I started believing in what I could
do and I remembered how to play and you
know I said he should offer to have your
son on the bag though I mean I'm
watching last night and I just see you
hug him in and your son even said you
know dad made it about me and at that
moment which was really cool to see well
you know to me it was having your son on
the bag and making the moment about you
and your son I think is I hope that's
what I'm about and you know what my son
my son has always been an important part
of my life so all my kids have been
important part of my life as my
grandkids are and it's it's something
that you know it's sometimes during an
event I'm playing the event I'm doing
what I have to do but
some point it turns around and you want
to share it with somebody and my son was
there and that's who I shared it with
he's Jack Nicklaus joining us on the
program I try to tell people about the
the sound that you have at Augusta like
you almost have sounds that for an eagle
or a hole-in-one or birdie almost
differentiate but that that's Sunday in
86 everybody talked about the noise like
you heard noise where Seve Ballesteros
was playing well Tom kite did something
but then there was a different roar when
you were doing something can you put
into words that sound that you have at
Augusta when you've done something great
well you know I think first of all you
have to understand it Gus for you
you know the clubhouse is on the top of
the hill and it's just one basic slope
down a hill and the all the sounds just
seemed to sort of vibrate and
reverberate out of the trees and and
come up the hill and so when you start
to hear things understand what's going
on and you understand that yeah you know
about where people are and all of a
sudden you hear a sound you say okay
that's somebody just made a just made a
birdie down there and or somebody just
made an eagle down there and you sort of
know who's in that area and all of a
sudden you say oh seve has just done
this or Jack's just done this or
whatever it might be you get if it's
different than any other place I've been
most other places it doesn't seem to all
crack to into an area and yet a gusset
seems to I guess one of the magic parts
about the place is Augusta always going
to be I know they they tried to Jack
proof it and tiger proof it but is the
course no matter what technology is
going to be able to still hold its own
oh this golf course always hold its own
and you know I think it's I think it's a
shame because I get on my soapbox about
the golf ball but you know the golf ball
goes too far and as a result there's
only one one golf course in the United
States in my opinion that's been able to
keep up with a technology standpoint and
can afford to do it that's Augusta
National everybody else every time you
have an event think they're struggling
to figure out how can they try to make
the golf course that will compete
against everybody else but I got to said
a great job and they
I go back and look at the golf course
and the clubs that the guys are playing
are pretty much relative to what I
played 25 years ago and or 30 years ago
whatever it might be they're playing
those same clubs but they've just the
tees and such that do it they've had the
space to do it
13th hole is one hole that they probably
haven't gotten there because he kept
you're trying to buy a part of Augusta
Country Club so they can move a tee back
and we couldn't because now they're just
taking it over the top of the trees
there's the old story when I was a kid
but Sam sneezes I used to drive it over
those trees and and and they all said
well how could you do that I said well
the trees were only you know 20 feet the
whole water Pete's all but times change
and so those 200 foot tall trees now or
you know the guys drive drive it right
over the top of them played eight to
nine hours and wedges into the green
what do you miss about competing
competing that's exactly what I miss her
you know I love competing I don't care
what it is and golf was my vehicle to
competition and when I lost my vehicle I
just you know it was sort of I lost my
ability to to play the game of golf and
compete and so it's just you know it's
okay we all do that and everything I do
in life I mean I'd you know I'm fishing
it's my competition against the fish or
playing tennis which I play a lot of
tennis I just you know I know I my
expectations aren't realized so that's
okay and but I compete at my level and
you know even today if I do play golf I
play with some of my friends and you
know I'm about a four handicap now Dan
and you know I've every once in a while
I'll find a little lightning in a bottle
and shoot a 72 or something and and
destroy my handicap but it's okay and
then I get a big kick out of that
well you I don't know if you take that
competition that that competitiveness
and you put it into business because you
got Jack Nicklaus ice cream and you got
Jack Nicklaus house why I mean you got
so many different things there are you
as competitive in in business as you
were in golf
well I try to be I think it's and you
know most people work all their life and
they sort of burn themselves out and
business-wise and then they retire they
play a lot of golf and like I did
exactly the opposite I played golf on
that life and now I'm retired from golf
to play to work and do business and
frankly I'm young at business so I'm
still enthusiastic I enjoy it enjoy the
competition of it I enjoy I enjoy going
out and going to new cultures around the
world and see them doing golf courses at
different places or I do like you
mentioned the ice cream I mean I've to
go in and out go ahead and see a lot of
CEOs of supermarkets that kind of stuff
doing things with people I never would
have done business with before and
frankly it is a competition if there's a
competition of how could I handle myself
and I I thoroughly enjoy it I certainly
have fun I'm having fun with it and you
know I'm here I'm 76 years old and I'm
working as hard as I ever worked and you
know not because I have to is because I
want to because I love it
I know that people have focused on 1986
and for good reason but you also won
twice when you were 40 years of age and
it made me wonder if is there hope for
tiger at age 40 that he could still
capture lightning in a bottle well I
don't think Tiger Neeson captured in a
bottle I think capture I think Tiger
will have plenty of lightning without
the bottle I think he's he's still a
young guy physically I mean I know he's
had some injuries but I think he's I
said next to him at the champions dinner
last night and we talked quite a bit he
seems to be really good and good spirits
he seems in good health he's not going
to rush his return and he's going to
come back when he's ready to come back
but he thinks he'll play well and I
think he'll play well too I just so I
think that maybe 10 years from now he'll
have to find some lightning but right
now I think he's still he'll be very
competitive when it comes back out of
Jordan speith do with his menu last
night Texas barbecue last night and it
was it was excellent the club did a
great job of it and Jordan was you know
he handled himself very well I think he
sort of was a little bit in awe of I
don't know how many of those where there
are 30-some
got 30 guys or so and he but as a 20 was
20 22 now yeah I suppose that he had he
handled himself very well he's a nice
young man and he's gonna win a lot more
masters he's gonna he's gonna have a lot
of fun here before I let you go did
somebody have a bad menu can you
remember down through the years that you
just went this isn't this isn't what I
want this isn't gonna go well no I don't
think anybody's ever had a bad man you
know well I think that would promise
what for most of us was sandy Lau's agus
but but we all we've always had an
alternate but you know I think that I
always got a big kicked out of the menu
when I first started in 1964 Bowman was
a guy who was running them the menus
here and Bowman came to me and he said
he said mr. dick cause he says what
would you like to have on the menu for
free her first dinner and I said well
whatever you suggest I said what do you
think well mr. Roberts does like to have
a a salad with that he like have a steak
he likes a baked potato likes green
beans they like peaches for dessert if
that would be all right and I said well
mr. Roberts would like that that's just
fine with me
so he planned your menus for you so he
planned my menu for me which was quite
all right with me yeah exactly planned
every one of them oh he did you didn't
pick out anything now I never picked out
a menu no I was on all he did was send
me to check what would you pick down
your steak and potatoes really the same
thing go that's probably the same thing
I'm pretty I'm pretty simple food wise
it's great to talk to you I hope you
enjoy the 86 documentary it was really
well done and hopefully it'll bring back
a lot of great memories for you and
thanks for joining us this morning okay
dance always nice to talk to you and
share yourself that's Jack Nicklaus the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience